[Music]
week one Power Rankings posted at
pro-football talk.com and look the
Patriots as Nick Saban recently said
when you climb the mountain you become
the mountain and they are the mountain
the hill is the hill the New England
Patriots at number one I don't know how
you can make the case for anyone else as
of right now they've won two of the last
three Super Bowls they'd been in for the
last five and the Patriots at the top of
the stack the Chiefs at number two I
don't think have a nation you have an
issue any issue with my top five no I do
not your top where time is fine the
first one you see that makes you think
I'm crazy well I mean III you think
you're crazy in general so let's not
forget that point okay but the Rams in
the Saints a seven and eight too low I
mean I guess I would have give them the
respect to be just a little higher to
start the season I know you and I are
both not like bullish on them and I
think you don't have either one going to
the playoffs right right so I was a
little surprised to see that right there
I wasn't sure if you were gonna make
them a little higher to give them
respect from last year or maybe a little
lower they would have been a little
higher I jumped the seahawks from 9 to 6
yeah ok so you're feeling good about the
Seahawks alright so that was my like one
little thing that jumped out to me about
the top 10 but wasn't like shocked and
then I think the next thing that jumped
out to you you had the Steelers in your
top 10 which is good to see yeah well
they should be in the top I think that
they have the talent even without an
Tonio brown and Le'Veon Bell writing
they have the attitude and the focus
this year this team has lacked the
discipline to get the most out of its
ability for whatever reason whoever we
want to blame Ben Roethlisberger mike
tomlin
someone else doesn't matter they haven't
been as focused as they need to be this
year they're focused just to prove that
the rest of us are wrong when they say
they're not as focused as they need to
be it's great that your lack of
appropriate discipline and attention to
detail turns into your motivation to
become disciplined and to pay more
attention to detail but whatever works
works yeah well it does well I mean as
we're seeing Antonio Brown stuff to deal
with I mean again I mean it's become so
commonplace for Antonio Brown to act
crazy we don't even talk about on the
show anymore we just put it on a pot o
$53,000 fine he's crazy since I the
tweet we don't even talk about it as
much because it's like crazy Ville every
other day with Antonio Brown but it
hadn't been for a while that's what's
weird
yesterday's thing was we it was weird it
was kind of out of nowhere but your top
10 I'm cool with that now when we get
through like 11 through 20
I got some questions for you because you
know or even 11 through I want to say 24
you got the Jets going the playoffs you
got them 24 thanks you got to start look
they've earned their starting spot okay
this this is a team so we have the Rams
and saints why didn't they are in there
but they they have it sometimes they get
some fuel based upon last year delicate
balance either it's kind of where you
are right heading into the season yes I
I think that the Rams did say it's gonna
be down I think the Jets are gonna be up
but I don't think this is a playoff
seedings prediction night you're just
saying start snapshot in time
right right now for those on radio
here's the top 10 the full top 10 one
Patriots two Chiefs three Eagles four
Cowboys five bears six Seahawks seven
Rams eight saints nine Steelers ten
chargers just missing out the Vikings at
11 the Browns at 12 you know look it's
not easy because no I know zero and zero
right somebody's got to be 31
I got somebody's got to be 32 well you
got to write i could tell you that
cardinals and dolphins deserve to be 31
and 32 that is for sure that's by a
longshot they are the two bottom teams
in football okay can I challenge you
some more no oh great wizard of power
ranked as long as you say that yes oh
great wizard of power rankings I cannot
believe you put the Vikings ahead of the
Ravens or the Panthers I think that's
the other one I look at because I know
you feel good about the Panthers we saw
with the morning laughs Cam Newton yeah
right so I was a little surprised you in
the Panthers that low because you saw
enough last year to go okay there okay
this year Cam Newton's gonna be healthy
but you just want to see some place I
want to see it when you lose seven out
of eight to end the seas you slide down
in the middle of the pack and I think
it's hard to justify putting them any
higher than that because of the way
okay last season disintegrated because
of the questions about Cam Newton I
personally believe yeah he'll be healthy
I believe they'll be good I believe
they'll beat the Rams this weekend I
believe that they'll they'll start a
playoff climb that culminates in them
beating in my estimation the Vikings in
the wild-card round yeah this is not
where teams are going to finish this is
where he starts why some people get
twisted up like Pete Prisco or buddy at
CBS yeah he has the Packers at number
one in his Power Rankings like you may
think they're gonna win the Super Bowl
but how how do you justify making them
the number
one team with all the questions that
they currently have you can't make them
number one in all of football absolutely
not no I have to throw to challenge that
and call rockets up the butt and to jail
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports